wait a minute
what is this
ryan reynolds says he's
not in multiverse of madness
tell me everything about your appearance
in the doctor strange movie oh wow mark
fun
it's like the least uh uh least covert
trap i've ever seen in my life you know
what is it is there a point of me saying
to are you in the doctor's arrangement
um yeah i don't i'm not really supposed
to i guess i'm really not supposed to
say anything about that but i'm really
not in the movie
i'm not supposed to say anything but i'm
really not in the movie you just said
something and you could be lying and you
could be lying i could be an unreliable
narrator but i promise you i'm not in
the movie
yeah
all those people we're good in that
movie we're good we're good there's a
team of people that will neutralize you
as soon as you leave
huh
this seems very familiar i ain't got a
call so like
okay not the werewolf i promise you i am
not the werewolf
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
ish it's andrew garfield playing
spider-man again no no no i'm not i'm
not i'm not
crying out loud
i'm peter parker
i am spider-man
i am the werewolf
so andrew garfield wasn't the werewolf
and apparently ryan reynolds isn't
either
i'm guessing there's probably a good
chance we'll see him in the movie